[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Cloud Spanner is
a no-compromise database,
combining the abilities
of a relational database
with horizontal scale.
It allows you to launch faster
and enjoy less administration.
This Quick Start shows you how
to perform basic operations
in Cloud Spanner using the
Google Cloud Platform Console.
When you first
use Cloud Spanner,
you must create
an instance, which
is an allocation of resources
that are used by Cloud Spanner
databases in that instance.
Click Create Instance.
We used Test Instance as the
name and ID of this instance.
Choose Regional Configuration,
and pick any configuration
from the dropdown menu.
Your instance
configuration determines
the geographic location
where your instances
are stored and replicated.
We'll keep the one for the
node count, and click Create.
Your instance appears in
the Spanner Instances page.
Now it's time to
create a database.
Go ahead and click
Create Database.
For the database name,
enter Example DB.
We'll skip the Define Your
Database Schema step for now.
We'll do that in
the next section.
Click Create.
Cloud Platform Console
displays some database details
after the database
has been created.
Next up, we'll
create a table schema
for your database using the
Cloud Spanner Data Definition
Language, or DDL.
Click Create Table.
And we'll flip the toggle
over to Edit as Text.
And in the DDL statement,
enter the following statement.
Click Create Table.
This may take a few
minutes to finish.
When the operation is complete,
the Cloud Platform Console
displays the details of the
table that you just created.
The Cloud Platform Console
provides an interface
for inserting, editing,
and deleting data.
We'll talk about
each one in turn.
Let's start with inserting.
Click Data and click Insert,
and type in the following data.
We'll do just the first
name and last name for now.
And then click Save.
Notice now, the Singers
table has one row.
Let's click Insert again
and add an additional row.
Enter the following
values for our second row.
And click Save.
Notice the Singers
table now has two rows.
You can also insert empty string
values when entering data.
We'll insert a third row.
This time, in addition to
the integer ID key of 3,
we'll just enter a first name
and leave the last name blank.
Click Save.
And notice now that the
Singers table has three rows.
And the row for singer
ID 3 has a last name
that is an empty string.
Let's take a look
at how to edit data.
We'll add a birth date to
that third row of data.
Check the box, and click Edit.
Enter the following values for
Birth Date, and click Save.
We see now that the
row for singer ID 3
in the Singers table
has a birth date value.
Let's talk about
how to delete data.
Deleting data is very
similar to editing.
Go ahead and check the box next
to the row for singer ID 2,
and click Delete.
In the dialog that
appears, click
OK to confirm the deletion.
Notice now that the Singers
table has just two rows.
Next, let's run a
SQL statement query.
From the Tables
page, click Query.
Now, just click Run Query to
run the prepopulated query.
The Cloud Platform
Console displays
the results of your query.
Congratulations.
You've successfully created
a Cloud Spanner database
and executed a SQL statement
using the query editor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]